understanding iido part one Marshall
context what is Marshall context
Marshall context is essentially the
situation which you're going to be using
the martial art form you're studying so
if I was going to be um in a situation
where it's me and one other guy and
we're going to be only punching each
other something like Western boxing
would be a great martial art to step
if we're going to be wrestling with each
other and no striking then Western
wrestling might be a great system to
study or Brazilian jiu-jitsu something
like that um the context of this this
the martial art is going to be the
situation which it's useful um it's
important to understand that martial
arts as a whole is a very large field
includes a lot of different disciplines
and a lot of different things however
when we use the word martial art we're
usually only describing one thing and
that's a situation where there's only
two people it's a one-on-one they're
versing each other and so like a dueling
style situation or sport competitive
situation and those people are going to
be unarmed so unarmed people in a
one-on-one conflict and these are also
generally going to be controlled
situations when we look at sport sport
martial arts so there's going to be an
environment we know there's going to be
a surface we're used to playing on
there's going to be a guy there who
enforces the rules that we've decided
upon the Situation's going to be closed
off so other people can't come and join
in so a cage or a ring or something like
that where other people can't come in uh
there's going to be no weapons or
anything else involved a very controlled
situation um iido is a Marti that
doesn't fit into this context at all in
fact in a lot of ways it's kind of the
polar opposite of this kind of situation
so trying to understand what iido is
from the major context that we look at
which is unarmed one-on-one fighting U
makes understanding iiko almost
impossible and we have to begin to open
up our mind to what different contexts
are out there so this is part one of
this video I'm going to go on to explain
later what the other contexts are um how
iido fits into its own context and
what's important in iido training thank
you very much